Behind these closed doors
at the oil and money conference,
spineless politicians are making deals and compromises
with lobbyists from destructive industries,
the fossil fuel industry.
People all over the world are suffering
and dying from the consequences of the climate crisis
caused by these industries.
Who we allow to meet with our politicians
and have privileged access to.
The world is drowning in fossil fuels.
Our hopes and dreams and lives are being washed away
by a flood of greenwashing and lies.
It has been clear for decades
that the fossil food industries
were well aware of the consequences
of their business models.
And yet they have done nothing.
The opposite.
They have actively delayed
destructive
and denied the causes of the climate crisis
and spread doubt about their own engagement in it.
This is only the beginning of this fight,
and we are going to stay
and we are going to come back time and time again
until we see real action.
We cannot rely on politicians
and the people in power to save us.
They have proven time and time again
that they always prioritize the fossil fuel industry
and destructive industries above people,
above their own citizens.
So we have to reclaim the power,
and that is what we are doing today.
We have to kick oily money out.